متابعين منصه الجزيره الرقميه نحن الان
نتواجد في قريه دوتوريت الواقعه بجماعه
يعقوب هذه القريه هدمت بالكامل جميع
سكانها للنزول الى سفح الجبل والاستقرار
في خيم طلعنا الان رفقه احد سكان هذه
القريه
سنحاول تفقد المنازل المهدمه يحكي لي ان
الرائحه قويه رائحه الذواب التي لم
يتمكنوا من
استخراجهم تحت الركام
سنتجول معه او سنتفقد الاحياء التي تعرضت
للدمار الكامل
الدار ديالكم
ولكن
هنا هنا اللي فيه الغلام ديالنا والبقار
والدجاج وكل جهه البلاصه فيه بحال الكوريه
حدا التريب عليهم
هذاك المشكله
هذا الدار ديال جاري
توموبيل ديالي
وتهدم البلاصه
البصله
على حساب الفلاحه
لا اله الا الله
الباب بغينا بغينا الباب ولكن البابلوكه
فين نعس وفين ترى لي هذا الشيء والدراري
فين جبناهم
انا نعست في هذه البلاصه
في هذه البلاصه
وملي جاءت تقطع الضوء ولقيت الدراري هنا
ها هي
لقيت بنتي الكبيره هنا وتدرس غير ما شفناه
كاين في هذه البلاصه حتى
غير يدو
امي مسكينه درنا واحد البلاصه
وتقول وكل شيء
الثلاجه اجي من هنا اختي
واحد البيت كاندير فيه
تحت اسميته كل شيء
يبقى هنا الكوزينه
[موسيقى]
الناموسيه مدمره يعني
اللي عندها باقي التليفون باقي التليفون
شعل خدام الضوء هما الدوره ولقينا هنا
وجاو الدراري هما
البنات واحد الدري تما كلشي كيبانو غير
الرصافي وجاب الله بخير الحمد لله
انا انا
وخويا وجيران جبنا هادو نشرناهم فم الدار
ومشينا عند الاخرين كنجيو عند التضامن
الله بعدا شدينا شويه وكان
على هادشي ديالنا راه بقى هنا
يلا شوف المنظر شوف كل شي كل شيء الخساره
لا اله الا الله اشوف كاين واحد البيت
هنايا حتى هي
كاين
ناقص الان على سقف المنزل الذي كان يقطن
فيه احد سكان هذه القريه
توضح
المشاهد الدمار كامل تعرض له البيت لحسن
الحظ ان الجميع لم يتعرض لجروح او اصابات
بالغه لكن السيء في هذه المنطقه هي رائحه
الدواب الكريهه التي لم يتمكن السكان من
استخراجها من تحت الركام